[Música]
já usamos um dos meus filhos pequenina e
com quatro anos tinha no ar durante a
passagem de ano em que nós falávamos do
plano e está no e bom né no epfiiz ano
novo e de lá deve ter ouvido a palavra
muitas vezes e no dia sinto perguntou
mas quando é que o ano nós já tínhamos
passado - quando eu e não seja o que
quer um ano ea explicação de que é um
período de 365 dias em que a terra lá a
fazer uma revolução em torno do sol e
nascer muito fácil então eu entrei numa
agenda que era uma agenda anual um livro
e explicar e que extrai cada página
corresponde um dia aí aqui os dias todos
juntos são a seria um ano e de repente
tínhamos um instrumento em que
conseguimos os dois de ver com a minha
cara passa humana quando ele quer o
próximo aniversário quanto tempo faltava
com as férias eo penteado ambientado
daqui o volume de folhas ou eu era um
caso o papel é isto passado
é isto faz-nos pensar de fato que essa
materialização nos permite não só
entender mas também articular aquilo que
aqui estava sendo difícil explicar mas
passado
no fim deste dia quando estava nos eua
quando eu estava em casa e ouviu esse
meu filho para um filho mais pequeno que
havia um trompete no qual estavam a
tentar tirar som e dizer olha só treinar
muito
quando coisas legais muito trombeta
quando chegar ao fim da agenda já sabe
tocar a vender a meta trouxe esta
questão de fé ea propósito tempo isto um
ano pode ser uma das folhas e umas 11 11
uma semana o meia pode ser aqui uma umas
folhas destas não esta que irá prever
como está organizado estamos há fato de
uma estrutura tempo mas também o registo
que nos permite visualizar coisas
agora eu como designer e suavizar
são sohan em o que eu faço e design
gráfico é e cria falados iniciou nesta
questão de visualizado processo ou seja
as imagens que o esta imagem outras que
vão de estresse que são imagens que
fazem parte desse processo que existe em
outras disciplinas nos desagrada existe
também claro mas em que as nossas
ferramentas passa muito construir coisas
visuais e temos bastantes ferramentas o
que trabalhamos não só para um produto
final mas para este processo de entender
ou aquilo que temos em mãos aquilo que
temos que procurar ver que eu tô temos
que explorar organizar sistematizar
encontrar padrões encontrar o inusitado
tanto todo este processo de perceber
qual é o material que temos nos permite
encontrar narrativas mas também alguma
descoberta no material que temos em mão
e essa parte descoberta que no meu
processo como designer me interessa mas
que nuno outras disciplinas também vai
entrar bastante o tanque neste processo
então procurar poderá ser pra construir
objetos e aqui todos a mostrar exemplos
neste aqui por exemplo venha mesmo a
construção de um livro mas neste
processo visuais pois nós estamos
atentos no resultado final
mas então nesse interesse por outras
disciplinas altura este processo
visualização nos ampliam a comissão fui
dar a ciência está mas é então que
estava nos mostrar um pouquinho 238
tempo mas que são designers que os
cientistas também desenha muito bem este
lugar não quer ver notas sobre a
limitação das espécies em 3-2 primeiros
desenhos desta árvore russel e acho
muito bonito no canto superior esquerdo
tem eu penso
este é dos jogos nó o pai epidemiologia
moderna que através deste mapa
conseguiu amo maquiando os casos numa
crise numa uma epidemia de cólera em
londres
estamos a falar meados do século 19
conseguiu alma piar esses casos perceber
que estavam próximos
em miami também uma fonte de água e
permitiu então a se infectar seria pela
água e não pular que cobra a cestaria é
[Música]
espalhar este é um design um design uma
quase uma tabela do medo ft organizando
esta sistematização do que é visual de
uma sistematização das propriedades dos
rendimentos e estes a entrar água a
tabela periódica uma uma velhice uma
apresentação visual da classificação
geral - e este já vi um gol de charles
numa das chances que a maioria já
mostrou do painel e no processo de
descoberta com contributos não é que não
são só do este design é do james clique
aqui vemos o watson mil click
a própria constituição a descoberta o
colchão este modelo permite encontrar
definir mas descobrir essa essa procura
não é ea reforma do ar e no entanto
temos o design temos a ciência e uma
viseira atitude também nesta relação ao
design ciência ea e na apresentação de
maria joão
vimos alguns exemplos mas a comunicação
da ciência para fora da comunidade
científica
eu acredito neste potencial grande na
construção da alguma coisa na descoberta
de alguma coisa ou no na reflexão sobre
alguma coisa e entre chico e na gestão
de fretes que aqui eu tentando
sintetizar temos o design como um
construtor dos significados a
subjetividade amigo irá estar patente
está latente no material que recebemos
mesmo trabalho que temos no material nos
acho que temos a maior já que virado e
enquanto com deficiência me interessa
aqui enquanto o sistema representações
temos um modo gente virá de uma vez
tirada que também é o que torna a vala
eleita e faz parte dessa da sua prova do
seu próprio paradigma tem um lado temos
o a disciplina do olhar
o design também poderemos ter em
situação no olhar e no questionamento
também do que poderá ser o design e uma
proposta era um design pior né que
promove um quarto participa numa numa
questão do do próprio que o
questionamento sun do enunciado e agora
vou falar dois eventos neste sentido
nesta 1
nesta conversa nesta nesta comunicação
muito rápido
o em que foi o design é ciência com as
coisas que parecem fundamentais aqui a
primeira esta questão da colaboração é
que este caso está em mais de 50 anos o
que é o organismo vai ser um estuprador
trabalhava com um investigador da
bioquímica e trabalhavam sempre os dois
muito juntos muito próximos e e ou seja
era um ilustrador que conseguiria
desenvolver as imagens que um bioquímico
também estaria a criar e engraçado neste
caso no quando morreu o vinhais no
obituário o dique celular york michael
dizia que nunca tenho a certeza que
serei eu que escrevia para ilustrações
2006 eram originais e os travar os
ganhos de hoje portanto acho que é um
exemplo muito particular de colaboração
e outra questão tem a ver com o desafio
grande desafio e naquela postos urgente
virar objetividade amil idade que são
questões bastante complexas mas acho que
esse é um desafio
esta imagem é lindíssima provavelmente
alguns já foram conhecer o que é uma uma
colônia dura que foi fotografada por uma
fotógrafa do e mike que é feliz franco
que trabalha com cientistas não é como
fotógrafo e trata mas seus desafios
nesta imagem
ela moveu a placa de petri e imagem
flamengo ficou pior efe
e foi captada saif mais vista mas foi
uma grande loja polêmica por fatos
desafiou convenções transmissões estão
radicados na comunidade científica nas
revistas científicas
mas isso também poderá ser um desafio
não é de mudar a forma de dizer mas de
desafiar as formas na euforia diferentes
formas de ver othelito pensando aqui e
nesta nesta eu arrumando não é que o que
eu tenho pra fazer
acho que foi isso aqui um caso eu tô no
levar não é vimos a carinha sociedade e
ciência vai na ciência
maria joão açúcar tem que fazer um spin
deejay 500 nos incidentes
mas tanto interessa a esta parte em
personagem que interessa pensar na
questão do design da representação
visual pode ser um contributo ou o
design representar um contributo para a
investigação científica
no fundo eu acho que isso acaba por ser
a pergunta não é que é o que eu espero
manter mesmo depois de conseguir uma
terminar um do outro - não é que esse
poder ao design citar o olhar da ciência
e esta pergunta com ong como uma
diferença na minha motivação futura
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]